1 minute It's
cherry blossoms again this year, but he's back
Oh
, you ate Sugimoto, didn't you eat Shiraishi too?
The
grass is getting really sweet. I made it through the long winter with ingredients that I made the whole
run, so it's a very happy season to be able to eat fresh
vegetables.
It's a bittersweet taste of spring
.
All the words and beliefs of the
local Ainu, mixed with the blood of the Ainu who live in my home and this land,
you will become a
new Ainu woman,
and
you will become a guide to the Ainu.
But from now on, I'll never forget to teach you
[Music]
How long have you been sleeping for 4 days since the game ended This pig meru-Leaving bowl
Yubari is still far
away I'm in a bad mood I guess your sister stinks